welcome home we're delighted to have our
alumni back here with us I don't know
how long it's been for some of you even
if it's been three or four or five years
you will see change on this campus Rick
alluded to that and I'll come back to it
but i also want to mention the football
game record would want me to do that
actually the Carnegie Mellon football
game is going to be on national TV I
think it's a delay I think it's actually
shown tomorrow probably a four in the
morning or something no come on that was
a joke
dog tell don't tell Richie that I said
that I'm in big trouble it's on ESPNU is
the first time the Carnegie Mellon
football has been on national TV in 25
years now it's not because we've selling
decided to go big time in sports don't
worry we're not going to do that we're
still division 3 and proud of it but
we're also proud of our football team
which has had I think 28 non losing
seasons in a row and we expect to have
another one this year there has been
great change here no matter how long
it's been since your way if you happen
to be a way in the last week you
probably would notice change when you
came back i exaggerated but there has
been great change you see it in the
building's Rick mentioned this building
you've undoubtedly noticed the new gates
in hillman centers under construction
the News Center for computer science
that's being built in a part of campus
that if you're gone long enough you
would not believe that there would be a
building the Carnegie Mellon be using on
that spot we tore down four buildings to
make room for that so they're going to
be a phenomenal facility for computer
science but it's going to transform the
campus first by putting a building a
useful building in a part of campus that
really got used in past and second of
all by providing a physical connection
between the cut as we call this part of
the campus and that part of the campus
which is actually 75 feet lower and
you'll get there by going on a
footbridge from the pre Nell center
itself a new building for the School of
Drama a foot bridge that takes you from
the pronounced Center to the new
computer science complex that foot
bridge by the way it will be named for
Randy Pausch our professor who died of
pancreatic cancer and that bridge will
deliver you
I'll come back to Randy later that
bridge will deliver you too I don't know
what floor in the computer science
complex and into a ramp that will take
you down three floors into the level of
the new campus I can put it that way a
part of campus that will be completely
landscaped and beautiful not only will
it create this connection them but will
have hundreds maybe thousands of people
every day walking through this
magnificent computer science building
and that's the way we want this notion
about openness that referred to and that
we heard from our alumni at the alumni
awards last night is absolutely true
about Carnegie Mellon in a key trait and
something that were capturing and
preserving in our buildings themselves
so that's the computer science building
that's next door to the newell simon
building which for many of you seems
like a new building though for us now
it's been there for I don't know seven
or eight years I guess the current home
of computer science and of course name
for herb Simon and Alan Newell the two
great leaders in computer science and
next to that is a building that opened
three years ago a collaborative
innovation center we call it or see I
see a building built to attract R&D labs
of major technology companies and that
company is filled with Intel Apple and
Google the only building in the world
that can make that claim and they're
right on the edge of our campus just a
few feet away from computer science they
love it we love having them they've
grown very rapidly google has said that
they'll get as big in Pittsburgh as will
let them in terms of providing
facilities and people or allowing them
access to people that they can hire it's
been a tremendous success for the
University and significantly for
Pittsburgh and southwest Pennsylvania
one of our priorities so yes the campus
has changed
our academic programs have changed we've
got new degree programs and some of them
I'll touch on in the course of my
comments we become a global university
with campuses and programs in Europe and
the Middle East in particular in Qatar
and many in Asia and in Australia all of
this has happened relatively quickly so
but while we've changed and here's maybe
my most important message to our alumni
especially is that as much as we've
changed physically terms of our programs
where we teach our programs I don't
believe we've changed at all in terms of
the kind of institution we are Carnegie
Mellon to an unusual degree among
universities knows who it is knows what
we stand for Carnegie Mellon people know
what Carnegie Mellon stands for there
are few core values that we've never
lost sight of and I would say we've
enhanced and strengthened them over the
years and it's the same core values
around which Carnegie Tech was organized
when you when you attended here or
Carnegie Mellon depending on when you
were here and there easily stated no
maybe not so easy to sustained
commitment to problem solving and
particularly solving problems that
matter in the world lately we've been
also characterizing that as our being a
university that measures its excellence
through its impact not just by the
number of papers we publish problem
solving and the solving of problems that
matter collaboration and teamwork
usually expressed in the form of
interdisciplinary collaboration
engineers and artists working together
business people computer scientists
working together scientists natural
scientists and social scientists working
together this happens routinely a
Carnegie Mellon in fact if it doesn't
happen we think something's gone awry
and if there's a faculty member new one
who isn't playing with others well we
think they probably haven't been paying
attention to what Carnegie Mellon is all
about and they probably won't stay here
that's how committed we are to this and
we inculcate it into our students as
well within our academic programs and
third and one I know every Carnegie
Mellon person can identify with is our
commitment to hard work to getting the
job done doing what it takes to get the
job done my heart is in the work we
actually believe that we celebrate that
we behave in a way that is very
consistent with that these values if you
studied here any time in the last 60
years are exactly the values on which
Carnegie Mellon and Carnegie Tech was
based when you were here and they're the
same ones that motivate us today not
every University could say that matter
not every University would even know
this I I would venture to guess maybe I
shouldn't say this as you might go out
and try to try to do this improve me a
complete liar but my guess is if you
stop students on the cut and ask them
quick what are three things that define
Carnegie Mellon for you I'm not sure
what they'd say actually I I'm sure one
of the three would be hard work I can
guarantee you that I think if they were
thoughtful about it you would get
teamwork and collaboration and if you
sort of prompted them you probably get
problem-solving out of them to them
though they might have a different name
for that might these days actually say
fun that's something new about Carnegie
Mellon on
that's certainly so anybody here
graduated in the 80s yeah if I asked you
that you would not say fun I'll bet you
that of course well maybe not you if you
did you made your own fun let me put it
that way I guess they still do but we
make it easier to have fun at Carnegie
Mellon today these core values are
absolutely essential to us and we never
forget them now that's important for an
institution that's a century old and
wants to be centuries more older in the
future at any time but it's especially
important during tough times you know
where we're in for some rocky times the
world is and Carnegie Mellon is not
immune to that we're going to get hit by
the economic turmoil that's hitting our
country and we'll be hitting the world
and having a strong sense of who you are
and what makes you what you are really
is important at times like that we know
who we are and we're proud of what we
are and we hope you are too this these
values have also made us distinctive not
just in a way the fact that we know
ourselves but it's produced a way of
teaching a way of doing research a way
of behaving as an institution which sets
us apart there really is such a thing as
Carnegie Mellon people in a Carnegie
Mellon way and they are different from
other ways and other people that you
might think of we were reminded of this
in a pretty significant way the Latin
last academic year actually a few months
ago last spring when we went through our
once every ten year reaccreditation
process it's the kind of thing you got
to do whether you want to or not every
ten years every institution of higher
education America must be accredited
it's a very long drawn out and involved
process that involves hundreds of people
reduces thousands and thousands of pages
of material to explain to the
accrediting body what Carnegie Mellon
does and how is it that we think we
measure up to the standards all 14 of
them that they have that you've got to
meet in order to be accredited now in
our case that we were really concerned
about being reaccreditation Steen 21 or
Carnegie Mellon after all it would be
earth-shaking in America for Carnegie
Mellon ought to be reaccreditation to
reflect on how we're doing and I'll tell
you there's no University more
self-critical and more analytical about
that than Carnegie Mellon is about
itself indeed that was all part of the
process this time around however even
though we were confident about being
reaccreditation in public opinion about
higher education in this country and not
for the better it's much more skeptical
reviewed as sometimes is sort of greedy
because we charge such high tuitions I
understand the point as not accountable
we were not helped by the fact that the
government created a commission to
review the state of higher education
yeah this was the so-called Miller
Commissioner the Spelling's Commission
Secretary of Education Margaret
Spellings created it and they're
pointing departure was basically when
did you stop beating your spouse I mean
it was like you're guilty before even
charged and they really came after
higher education now they didn't have
Carnegie Mellon in their gunsights they
were but they had this sort of belief
that universities in America generally
have failed the country by producing
generations
of graduates who don't really have the
skills and knowledge that the
universities claim that they do am
presume we believe that they do again I
don't believe they if one had ever said
any of them what do you mean you talked
about Carnegie Mellon like I said oh no
no not currently melon indeed they
weren't but rather they were talking
about the nine Carnegie Mellon's if I
can put it that way you know there are
4,000 institutions of higher education
in this country even though they were
talking about us we go through the same
accreditation process that every other
university does so we were worried and
this concern and the sort of skepticism
in the air was manifest in particular in
terms of what they call assessment
student outcomes assessment and what
they mean by that is how can a
university prove to the public to the
world that our students really know what
we claim they know how do you know that
they've really learned calculus and in
particular the dimensions of calculus or
business or whatever they're studying
that's called assessment the other thing
we were worried about was general
education now that's not a concern of
most universities but it is here because
we approach general education the sort
of non the parts of students program not
in their major we approach that
differently than most universities and
most universities there is a core
curriculum a set of course is that every
student must take the Carnegie Mellon's
only one course everybody has to take
that's computer skills workshop or
Carnegie Mellon what can I say
it really it's the only course required
of all students I sensei students don't
have required courses but the
requirements are set by their college or
their department even depending on on
the program including their general
education requirements that is each
department at Carnegie Mellon is free to
determine how in their view their
student should get broadening in their
educational experience this made the
creditor is very nervous about Carnegie
Mellon because we break the mold well
they came they being a team of about a
dozen senior administrators and faculty
from other universities that's how we do
accreditation they came from four days
and after the first day they met with me
and they said we are so impressed we
can't believe how good you are and all
the things that they were concerned
about in fact indeed some of the special
meetings they had scheduled to pursue
questions like assessment general
education they canceled and said well we
don't really have to pursue that because
we're convinced and what convince him
more than anything was a meeting they
had had had with 50 of our students by
the way the students self-select that we
did not choose them they were so
impressed by our students and what our
students had to say about their general
education experiences and about they
could see for themselves an assessment
in action in a way because these
students were so self reflective about
what they did here I want to say a
little bit more about the general
education thing because it really
captures something special about
Carnegie Mellon one way to think about
this is one of our colleagues put it
this way and I kind of like the metaphor
if you think about the way most
universities do undergraduate education
it's like a funnel students come in I
mean an upside-down funnel or the wide
parts at the bottom so students come in
and they're all more or less taking the
same stuff
it's all very broad they want them to
take you know to from column a and one
from column B and then around their
sophomore junior year they start getting
specialized in their major so it's a
funnel I guess I could have put at the
top going down but you get the point you
start broad in any narrow and then you
narrow Carnegie Mellon turns the funnel
upside down you're admitted as an
engineer we are emitted as a humanities
scholar you're admitted as a business
major from the very beginning you are in
the narrow part of the funnel if you
will and from the very beginning unlike
students in a lot of places you start
learning about your chosen major in
profession which is actually a good
thing we don't over do that but students
get into it right away there's sort of
thrown into the deep end of the pool if
you will now at the same time tho those
your major is determining what else you
ought to be doing because surely to be a
great business leader you have to know
more than just finance or economics you
have to know how to write do you ought
to be exposed to the Arts you certainly
should study history and humanities
political science etc we all know that
and we know that here at Carnegie Mellon
but as a university we don't tell the
tupper school your students have to do
this we let them decide what the best
general education exposure for a temper
school student would be and it's
produced some wonderful things I have to
tell you so for example the tepper
school back to the temper school they
think their students should have more
writing courses than any other of the
other majors around except of course if
you're majoring in writing you get more
writing than a pretty but other than
non-running majors they require
additional writing courses for their
students Bravo good for them that's a
good thing I mean the future leaders of
business in this country in the world
ought to do that kind of thing
another thing that's happened though is
that as a university we've sought to if
I can put it this way layer on top of
what the departments and colleges
require their students a series of
course opportunities I'll put it that
way that touch on major global themes
that we think all students should be
exposed to we as a university think they
should be exposed to but again without
requiring a particular course what I
have in mind is our series of courses
related to green issues energy and
environment with a grant from the luce
foundation some years ago we created 30
additional environmental courses in all
seven of our colleges that are
accessible to students at all levels
including their first year we did a
similar thing have started a similar
thing in terms of international issues
global issues all aspects of global
issues and in this case we've got a
grant from the Carnegie Corporation
Carnegie Foundation that allowed the
allowed us to do this and again it's
there are international courses being
developed in each of the college's so
when students here get exposed to
international issues it's not just by
going to an international relations
program but it's taking a course that
deals with international business issues
in the tempur school if you're a
business student or managing
international engineering projects if
you're in CIT it's terrific a third is
ethics thanks to the generosity of Lois
Steinbrenner an alumnus and member of
our Board of Trustees we were able to
create some ethics modules that were
incorporated into courses throughout the
university and let me give you an
anecdote actually I used it yesterday we
had a board of trustees meeting which is
my favorite example of how this works
few years ago we did something I was
proposing to do something that upsets
students imagine Carnegie Mellon
students getting upset about something
and upset enough to have a petition
writing campaign and getting 800
petitions in protest and the two student
ring later ringleaders made an
appointment to see me and keep marching
into my office and the spokesman's
started out by saying I'm a sophomore
and I'm thinking God and I could not
have said even that much as a sophomore
Taylor president I'm a sophomore Adam
I'm a major computer science and in my
robotics course last semester we had two
weeks on ethics and what you're doing
mr. president is unethical I could have
kissed this kid I thought it was
magnificent now and if we said every
computer science student has take a
course in ethics in the philosophy
department it just this when it happened
he got it in a in a two-week module
embedded into his robotics course
brilliant that's the way Carnegie Mellon
does things this is I know if it's
unique I don't know enough about the
4,000 institutions of higher education
but i can tell you among our peers it is
unique and it is a very powerful way to
do undergraduate education that's why
we're so proud of our students and
they're doing such wonderful things i
could go on but it seems like i've used
almost all my time just on that issue
alone let me just mention we have
invested a great deal in facilities and
in programs in expanding and enriching
the extracurricular activities for our
students there's so much more that
happens on this campus now and happened
ten years ago and certainly 20 or 30 or
40 years ago all good all is very
exciting much of a student conceived in
student run its which is the best kind
in one example of this is that for our
first year students we started recently
a few years ago a program we call the
big
this program the idea is that to develop
small discussion groups within the
dormitories not in the classroom it
within the dormitories talking about big
questions well the meaning of life which
is probably the biggest question you can
think of this last year over the summer
after Randy pouches book the last
lecture was published we sent a copy to
each of our new students all 1413 or 50
freshmen coming in and that became the
basis for the big questions discussions
it was a wonderful and his an ongoing
wonderful experience for these students
you know in a lot of ways a chance to
talk about big deep questions but also a
chance to interact with students very
very different from themselves early on
in there Carnegie Mellon experience let
me say a little bit about Randy I mean
he was an amazing person and one of the
things about Randy was that he what you
got is what you saw so the persona that
you might have seen on TV the person you
think he was by reading his book or
watching his last lecture that really
was Randy you know that we it was
completely genuine and another thing
about Randy is that he loved Carnegie
Mellon absolutely loved current email in
fact one of the major reasons why he has
subjected himself to all the media
exposure he did as he was dying was to
promote Carnegie Mellon and it's
unbelievable actually and I've been
accused of stoop by students of
exploiting Carney Randy's notoriety and
his terminal cancer which I didn't
really appreciate but I understand that
was all Randy's Dylan and he always
insisted it be identified as a Carnegie
Mellon professor and be allowed to wear
a Carnegie Mellon t-shirt he was amazing
he was shamed
actually wait nemoto Carnegie Mellon we
will never know what impacts Randy and
Randy's story has had on this university
but one of the things that I no longer
hesitate to say because I think a lot of
people have felt this way I've come to
feel this way is that we should be very
proud that were the university where
Randy could develop the way he did as a
professor I'd like to say as a human
being but I think I'd give his parents
credit for that him Randy if he were
here would be the first to agree with
them he always felt that Carnegie Mellon
was truly special and that he could not
have done what he did anywhere else it's
not bad to be known as the university
that was Randy's University and probably
could have only been the only one that
could have been Randy's University
Carnegie Mellon has done phenomenally
well in research in recent years it's
not a new phenomenon but that just keeps
growing and getting better and more
impactful or a couple of things to keep
in mind about the way we do things here
which helps you appreciate what we have
achieved and give you gives you some
insight into what's to come first of all
the thing that I think is so important
is this collaborative spirit we have our
ability to work across disciplinary
barriers back to the Middle States the
accreditation team so one of the cuter
interactions I have with them was at
this meeting at the end of their first
day they said to us you really do
interdisciplinary collaboration I mean
totally aghast and we said yeah that
that's right we do and they said well
you know we claim to do it and we write
about it all the time at our University
just the way you do but you really do it
we never expected that and we said well
you know we wrote it as clearly as we
could in our self-study document they
said yeah but you know everybody writes
that and they encouraged us to think of
a new way of writing about a new term
for because interdisciplinary
collaboration is become so overused that
no one believes it anymore but in fact
that's our that's the way of life
accounting email that we are organized
around that idea it's totally part of
our DNA and it's the reason why we are
so successful and we have the impact we
do ray lane well I'm going to introduce
to you in a moment coined the phrase
disproportionate impact in talking about
Carnegie Mellon and he's absolutely
right about that we're not a large
University were smaller than most of our
peers and competitors but our impact is
far greater than our size and one of the
major ways we do that is by leveraging
what we have through interdisciplinary
collaboration collaboration is the key
for us a second thing I'd like to
mention is again appealing back to last
night's alumni awards ceremony and Rick
cited this one of our award recipients
who's now also when our an alumnus who's
now also one of our faculty members in
art said what i love about Carnegie
Mellon the reason I came back is because
of its openness and its willingness to
take risk love to hear them he had been
elsewhere he experienced universities
not as open or as willing as we are to
work outside of the mainstream by the
way this was an art professor talking
who works very heavily with people in
engineering and computer science and I'm
sure his stuff is edgy and I'm sure I'm
going to regret this someday when he
does something outrageous but that's all
part of the game we welcome the
opportunity
take risks not every risk we take
prudent risks in institutional Elona
comes to research when it comes to
exploring ideas there's nothing off the
table because it might lead us to
something new and better and maybe
breathtakingly so teamwork
interdisciplinary collaboration openness
and a willingness to take risk that is
Carnegie Mellon when it comes to
research and it's why we've had the
tremendous impact we've had we're doing
research in many many important areas we
just went through a year-long review of
our old strategic plan and just
yesterday our Board of Trustees approved
the new revised plan you can visit our
website to take a look at it if you want
to read it in more detail it focus is on
the same priorities from the old plan
but updated and revised and with regard
to research we have decided to focus on
a handful of we see its overarching
topics and issues let me emphasize these
are not exclusive that is doesn't mean
we're only going to work on these things
but things to keep our eye on and for
theme things for you to watch out on
watch out for and the top of the list is
energy and environment a major global
issue has been for a long time a many of
us feel that it's going to be the issue
for our children's generation I suppose
you could say regrettably health and
quality of life in area where we've made
great strides in the last decade and
expanding our life sciences faculty
another area and one where we're we're a
little bit hesitant because it's so bold
we can be poll but we usually don't talk
bold is transforming society through
information computation and
communication
not making society better not changing a
little bit transforming society through
information computation and
communication you know it's interesting
to watch this side and I did watch this
I didn't really participate that much in
the discussions we would not have said
this 10 years ago even though computer
science and computing information
technology and communications
represented one of our major priorities
from 10 years ago this shows a certain
confidence that Carnegie Mellon has
acquired it also shows that we've come
to realize that the way we do I have no
idea what I just did that could have
been a not-so-subtle message I get the
point
and I'm almost done I am done thank you
very much so you know I I forgot to note
that this is the closest Rick reach and
I will ever come to being in a scotch
and Soda presentation and now I know
what it's like you know to like be part
of the show we are so strong in these
areas and we've organized them in a way
that simply no other university is close
to and can even touch well I can go into
that invite me back sometime and I'll go
more deeply into that I'm delighted by
this and it is no less than what it
claims to be transforming every aspect
of society including by the way the way
we do sites one aspect of this by the
way is something called computational
biology and it recognizes the
opportunity that comes from the
convergence of information technology
with biotechnology it's what's going to
cure cancer it's what's going to develop
personalized medicine something you've
heard about and we've heard about for
some time and it's all organized around
the notion that we've got huge amounts
of data now the human genome for example
and much more coming but we don't really
know how to take advantage of that data
that's a computer science problem or a
computational problem and what we need
are biologists to computer scientist who
can work together well there's no better
place in the world for that to happen in
a Carnegie Mellon and we were delighted
that last year ray and Stephanie Lane
endowed the new range Stephanie Lane
center for computational biology devoted
to exactly what I'm talking about it's
my great pleasure to introduce to you
now ray lane ray is a member of our
Board of Trustees
and the chair of our capital campaign
he's the managing partner of kleiner
perkins caufield & byers the world's
leading venture capital firm he is also
a media star a bonafide media star
unlike me Rick having appeared on 60
minutes a couple weeks ago for his work
on electric power vehicles and having
been on the cover of the New York Times
Magazine for his other work in
environment ladies and gentlemen ray
lane
thank you all of us that have been
associated with Carnegie Mellon's last
hundred years are of course very very
proud of what the university has
accomplished what it represents today
its reputation and this weekend is all
about looking forward to the next
hundred years so in a small way we each
have an opportunity to be Andrew
Carnegie and think about and embrace and
be creative and innovative about the
vision for the university over the next
hundred years and of course be a part of
sharing resources to make it happen my
connection with Carnegie Mellon
University is personal I'm not an
alumnus but it is personal i grew up
here in Pittsburgh my father attended
Carnegie Tech he didn't do in a
traditional fashion for years and out he
started here and and family did not have
a lot of money and circumstances which I
will not bore you with just he couldn't
continue his education so he became a
project engineer at Blahniks designing
rolling mills in fact holds a few
patents for some of the rolling mill
designs that he has and but didn't but
he wanted a degree from Carnegie Mellon
so badly that he continued to pursue it
for 16 years night school class here
class there so I grew up with my father
attending the University and I have fond
memories of when I was 9 and 10 11 years
old coming to campus the same way we now
bring r.j. to campus and he is getting
that experience the other night I
stepped into CFA's for a and there was
Kresge Auditorium under renovation which
I'm sure it needs because i remember
when i was 10 years old attending
shakespeare plays
that he would bring me to he loved to go
to the Shakespeare plays even though he
was a mechanical engineer he knew the
value and the resources and the talent
this this University so when I was asked
guess now six years ago five years ago
to chair this campaign the same as when
I was asked no 15 or 16 years ago to be
a trustee of the university I
immediately said yes hirson California
where I live and people around me said
are you nuts cheering a campaign this is
real work this is really hard to do and
you're going to do it remotely and I
said well you know with a talent this
university has and the commitment that
has to build an advancement staff and to
reach out to as alumni base which have
nothing but the highest opinion for
Carnegie Mellon I actually think this
will be easy so I said yes the reason I
said yes goes beyond just my love for
the university over the last 20 years is
because I've worked at Oracle and booz
allen and Kleiner Perkins a lot of my
activity has taken me on two really
great campuses Harvard MIT Stanford
Berkeley I have seen a lot of
high-quality universities as I like to
recruit their students and it came it
was very evident to me that there was a
war on that there was a war happening
that was growing every day was I saw the
war chests that it was nothing short of
that believe me it's nothing short of
that when you see Stanford whatever it
is now 15 or 20 billion dollars in the
endowment in Princeton with 30 billion
dollars and its endowment and Harvard
with Everett you know these numbers are
unbelievable you don't know what to do
with the money it just sits in the
endowment and Carnegie Mellon
with less than a billion dollars and its
endowment well how does Carnegie Mellon
compete with Harvard and MIT and
Stanford Berkeley and other universities
have endowments that are 15 to 30 times
bigger and I looked at that as did all
the trustees as Tajiri and say you know
we can't it's going to be tougher and
tougher amazing that decisions I see
every day by faculty to stay here
because of their love for the university
knowing that they could get labs
graduate assistants bigger salaries you
know all the tchotchkes they want and
they stay here well that over a period
of time just starts to wear down and
finally some faculty might just say and
they have said you know I can't I can't
turn this down for my family for my
career so it takes resources we must
have the labs we must have the research
we must have the endowed chairs the
Intel endowed centers to compete it's a
war if we do not keep up if we do not
know in a billion dollars a billion
dollar campaign most of which goes into
the endowment is just keeping up if we
don't do that then be prepared to not
enjoy the reputation that we've enjoyed
for the last 20 years or hundred years
it's as simple as that it'll happen over
a long period of time but it will happen
because we won't be able to retain the
best that this test was no that's what
this is about sorry must be the mirror
turn that off so that's what this is
about it's it's about a war for talent
just like we see in corporations we see
in sports my god the rock stars should
be faculty you know why do we celebrate
sports figures so much when we should be
celebrating faculty academic achievement
he really wants to talk so that's what
it needs to be about and that's what we
need to celebrate and we do have rock
stars we do have rock stars and we need
to talk more about them so the
university began this campaign five
years ago would have achieved is really
remarkable 550 million dollars have been
raised already now we started the
campaign in a recession you could argue
whether it was a real recession but in
9th in 2001 2002 obviously the bubble
that I i lived in but the bubble burst
and we had a tech lead recession that
affected everyone's portfolio in some
fashion then 911 happened so as we
started a recession as 911 happens we
decide to start a campaign and Ray is
naive enough to share it okay and so we
started the campaign and and and we
didn't want to mention the B word we
didn't want to wear every was walking on
eggshells and talking about could this
be a billion dollar campaign should it
be more should we say this is a 850
million dollar campaign this doesn't
roll off the tongue as well so we didn't
talk
it in a Carnegie Mellon fashion we
didn't talk about it let's see how we do
let's let's start the campaign and so
five years have achieved 550 million
dollars in this campaign and this
weekend we go public and say in the next
five years we want this to be a billion
dollar campaign or more we're not shy
about the b-word anymore because we've
seen the friends and family of this
university give and give a lot it's more
than just simply raising the money you
know most campaigns in fact you have
some universities that never get out of
campaigns as soon as they end one they
start another one so it's not about
getting to a billion and say wow that
was fun we're done this is about
increasing the annual participation of
those that love this university this is
about engaging alumni maybe some of you
for the first time but stay engaged with
the university over your lifetime this
is about building a worldwide reputation
I delivered a commencement speech in May
of this year in Doha to the first
graduating class of Carnegie Mellon in
Qatar the worldwide reputation that is
well understood in many many countries
around the world and maybe maybe in some
countries better than the United States
so that's what this is about is to
change the game at this university and
all of its constituents and the support
of the university over time so as you
look at this campaign and examine what
it's about and your interaction with the
university you'll be asked and you will
ask why invest in Carnegie Mellon a lot
of places to invest now personally in
association with others charities there
there are no
shortage of places to invest and why
Carnegie Mellon and my simple answer is
because Carnegie Mellon deserves it more
than anybody else of all the
opportunities Carnegie Mellon deserves
your attention I spoke last night as we
always do in Carnegie Mellon try to put
things into a formula and I developed a
simple quotient and that is our
reputation per dollar the reputation the
disproportionate impact that Jerry
talked about that Carnegie Mellon
established in the world for the dollars
that are invested in that the outcome or
impact for the dollars that go in
greater than any other investment you
can make this tremendous whether you're
talking about the energy and environment
or you're talking about life sciences or
you're talking about next-gen computing
we expect Carnegie Mellon to save the
planet resolve cancer okay and and and
and make our children's and
grandchildren's lives much better than
ours that the mission is no less than
that for the Carnegie Mellon students
and faculty they're here today that is
the mission so we have to do our part to
support it so this is a again last night
he really wants to conquer me so last
night I talked about an innovation
culture that Carnegie Mellon has an
innovation culture you can find
innovative societies at MIT and Harvard
Stanford Berkeley and other places
there's no lack of innovation in our in
US universities it's maybe the last
great unique product that the United
States has is education if you just look
at how much of it we export
and there's no lack of culture you
believe me if you still go on to the
Berkeley campus you'll find plenty of
culture so but having them together very
unique here at Carnegie Mellon and I
don't need to tell you what Jerry has
told you very eloquently about our
multidisciplinary approach but last
night it's very understand we arrived at
the affair last night at around six or
six-thirty and it was raining a little
bit so he snuck in a side basement door
and cfa and at the bottom of the stairs
we're going to go up the stairs to the
10th in the bottom of stairs there was a
second year graduate student
percussionist practicing on his idol
phone it was really interesting to
listen to him play and so I introduced
myself and asked him about his
background he's from Cleveland and I
said boy it's Friday night seven o'clock
there's a party going on next door you
must be just boning up for a test or
something there's no says I want to play
in a symphony I mean he just he just hit
me right in the in the face with this
I'm going to play in a symphony I want
to play in the best Symphony and I know
the competition is going to be really
really tough and the only way I'm going
to get that job is work and work 24
hours a day at eleven o'clock when the
fireworks were over we were going out to
the car and came down those same steps
he was still there practicing Friday
night party going on fireworks going off
over his head I don't think he took a
break I said go upstairs there's a bunch
of desserts upstairs nobody's eating he
says okay
really amazing really an amazing story
so so this innovation culture is what
this campaign is about it is the way we
do the work not the work not the ideas
the way the ideas get accomplished and
delivered to society is what Carnegie
Mellon's kind of comparative advantage
is and we want to make sure we retain
that comparative advantage because
that's really hard to steal that MIT
will not have Stanford will not have
that I live in the shadow of Stanford I
see it every day they will not get it
that's what we want to protect with the
resources of this campaign thank you for
embracing the campaign thank you for all
you've done in the campaign and thank
you for being a part of the campaign for
the next five years thank you